if you've already finished your video
game backlog good news
there's more stuff to play in the new
month if you're an xbox live gold member
and want to know what you can grab for
free in may i've got you covered
first up on xbox one is v-rally 4. it's
a rally racing game if you couldn't
guess from the name
it's got over 50 cars from top makers
like porsche and skoda
and you can race them on tracks all
across the world as you aim for the best
time on each stage
b-rally 4 is up for grabs anytime in may
it'll be available
all month long xbox one's other free
game keeps the action going
warhammer 40 000 inquisitor martyr is a
mouthful
and it's basically warhammer but diablo
this action rpg has four classes to
choose from
and you can play the adventure solo or
in co-op inquisitor will be available to
download from may 16th through june 15th
now don't tune out just yet the 360
games are backwards compatible for you
xbox one players too
the first 360 game is sensible world of
soccer
which you might recall from the retro
amiga days
this is an enhanced version of that
top-down soccer game but you can toggle
the graphics back to the 90s look if
you're feeling nostalgic
sensible world of soccer will be
available from may 1st through the 15th
finally there's overlord 2 which was
last seen more than 10 years ago
you are the overlord and you command
your minions to cause havoc and take
over a roman style world
you can even step into battle yourself
using the overlord's powers if your
minions need a little boost
overlord 2 will be available from may
16th through the 31st
and those are your free games with gold
for may 2020 remember that you can
always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles on gamespot
and stay tuned as we report on the new
games with gold lineup every month
you